so there's growing uh pressure so called
from republicans for joe biden to be
screened for
dementia like donald trump was and this
all relates to the montreal cognitive
assessment or the mocha as it's called
which donald trump you might remember
took during his time
in the white house and trump hasn't
stopped bragging about the results ever
since
even at one point remember telling
reporters like chris wallace accusing
them during an interview
you couldn't do as well as me on those
tests
and trump keeps calling it a cognitive
test
trump brags about his great score and
how it proves
something i guess about his intelligence
the reality is i've told you before is
that this test is meant to screen out
serious dementia pretty serious advanced
dementia sometimes used to evaluate
patients after strokes to see
what their cognitive functioning is it's
not really something
to brag about it's just a very crude and
basic
screening tool to find out is something
really wrong here where someone has
forgotten you know what a camel
looks like now you might be wondering
why is this an issue now
again this is present now because
trump won't stop talking about it and dr
uh ronnie jackson
trump's former white house doctor who's
now a congressman
um is saying that joe biden should take
the test uh don jr is saying joe biden
should take the test
donald trump has now started saying that
uh joe biden should take the test but
in so doing trump just can't control
himself he can't stop bragging about the
test
trump went down to the u.s mexico border
with republican governor of texas greg
abbott
and they had like a little press event
and somehow
trump gets on the topic of his dementia
test and how biden should take the test
take a look at this
but he did a test did i ace it
i aced it and i'd like to see biden he
said he won't ace it he'll get the first
two there's 35 questions and
the first two or three are pretty easy
they're the animals
is this a lion a giraffe when he gets to
around 20 he's going to have a little
hard time i think he's going to have a
hard time with the first few actually
but so we really have something now
trump is just wrong about
basically everything as usual there
aren't 35 questions there are 30 points
there's really like 19 or 23 questions
depending on
how you count them so like even trump's
recollection of what the test
is is wrong but he keeps insisting with
it
but somehow trump is obsessed with the
test
here he is talking to sean hannity also
at the border part of his
mexico border propaganda tour that he
did last week during our vacation
listened to trump and sean hannity
helping to push this nonsense about the
difficulty of the test
i'm in trouble with his comments i think
i can say that i aced it
did he get one he didn't get one
question wrong did he 30 out of 30.
wow i have to tell you the crowd
cheering is just something else i mean
they're they're cheering for what is a
normal
state they're cheering for not suffering
from serious dementia these are people
who would clap for
anything consider what it is they're
clapping for it's pathetic
the president passed a test meant to
screen
for serious cognitive impairment yeah
what a manly guy our leader here's the
rest of the clip and trump again saying
the test is just
much tougher than the media will tell
you and they did get a little more
difficult after you got by 15 i would
say but
i heard the first three questions are is
it a giraffe or an elephant right
well you know that's what the fact is
they take the first two or three
questions and they put that
and they put them in but let me tell you
they would not get those last
15 right certainly not the last 10 that
i can tell you but
anyway so again uh dr ronnie jackson
trump's former doctor
now just a bomb-throwing congressman
also
pushing this and uh saying
um that something is going on biden
needs a test and just to remind you
about the test by the way
this really is an easy test um we've got
it up on the screen i mean it's
you know stuff like draw a clock that
shows that it's 11
10 identify a lion
a rhino and a camel remember
repeat back to me the words face velvet
church
daisy red read a list of digits and then
you know you count them back like the
the tester would say two one eight five
four and you have to say two one eight
five
four or repeat the numbers backwards
seven four
two and you say two four seven um
subtract by seven out loud you know like
a hundred ninety three eighty six
seventy nine
this is the test um when trump says
there are tougher questions
you know there's one called abstraction
which is like what are the similarities
between train and bicycle to which you
would say oh sir
those are methods of transportation or
uh you know things republicans oppose
depending on your perspective
a watch and a ruler well both of those
help you
measure different things the watch
measures time and the ruler measures
length
this is what they're this is the
difficult test that trump is talking
about so
it's all pathetic um it seems to be
another distraction narrative
quite frankly and it is bizarre that
donald trump is still obsessed with it
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much i
love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you 20 off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put
in my living room at home it's now my
favorite piece of furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up it's
solidly built it's huge it's roomy
it has a modern minimalist design which
i love but it's also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality
it has become the focal point of my
living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now
and get 20 off your entire order when
you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video